pulsano a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questa nuova bisogno di pubblicità
giapponesi reaction aiuti episodi sono
stati i migliori in assoluto delle
pubblicità giapponese non è perché siamo
arrivati a di livelli estremi ma non è
mai abbastanza next one led da un
concerto a viggianello questa partita
fermi fermi ci vuole una descrizione
prima che vi sia pubblicità e ve la dico
io tesoro viene a trovarmi a casa non
possa amore sono ancora in ufficio sono
tutta nuda
esse hanno dovuto spiegare perché sono
ecco perfetto non si capiva
ok ovviamente questo è quello che dico
io che non la macchina
questa questa è un'altra amore viene a
guardare spider man con me non possono
reso ancora in ufficio sono tutta nuda
sì il mio spider man
a quel punto che max finiscono cazzate
va bene la ministra e molto sexy ma star
ma guarda 6 c ma sta ovviamente dalla
pubblicità di una roba che si teme non
ci sta e prima ancora per un po air one
box next ho già partiti da dio
andiamo avanti perché no no spero ti
abbiano dato un sacco di soldi
un'amica spero ti abbiano dato un sacco
va bene va bene il re di bellissimo l'ha
detto preciso che ho detto io così 10
basta roba da bere basta roba da bere
basta veramente basta le palle che palle
viva tutte le parti però
la vas mi fa piacere però passano per
avere veramente basta mangiate altri ma
tante volte
insomma sembra che sembra che l'economia
giapponese vada avanti scopre link ma
che cacchio è ben dylan automobile ben
di un hamburger sono robe da bene non
capisco e videogiochi aver finito la
lazio per come sempre anche mick
rapinare patrick ci manca solo quello
il sogno sola sbattendo
e come si vota simonetta di rete nei
ragazzi un posto delle solo via mare
hanno rimandato le olimpiadi tra
ovviamente per tutto il casino però tra
l'altro io volevo andare quest'anno
proprio perché detto chissà come la cup
che poi tocchi e incredibile chissà come
la cambieranno per le olimpiadi cava che
vanno rimandate però io sono dell'idea
che poi quando faranno veramente il
tokyo 2020 2021 andrà ancora meglio
proprio per il fatto che è stata
rimandata quindi ci sarà molto più
supporting vi siete mai chiesti che cosa
c'è all'interno dei panini del mcdonald
[Musica]
tutto questo casino per fare un vassoio
ok gatto che giocava con una corriera
point a rho e quello brava di lei di
tutto come zio thai che m'ha dato
accettare per un gatto con la valigetta
accordare io lo capisco sempre sto
problemi solo da chiederlo a sa ma
perché è impossibile che te lo dice che
poi tu non ci credi ma guarda dimise
sembra normale guardava la e lo so che
non è normale lo so non capisco subito
spiegazioni
forse me sono meglio i gatti con la
valigetta soprattutto quando fanno
queste espressioni ragiono io non ho
capito niente però avevo caso si rimasto
in casa nello scorso c'era quella con la
faccia la gelatina in questo mettiamo
quello con la faccia ha generato va beh
ci sta legami tutto baby it's moda
lavori sono i romani che cosa ha detto
vorrei sapere il giapponese per capire
che la salita il giorno
[Musica]
poi cosa
inizio quelli veramente non so più cosa
dire siamo arrivati a dei punti in cui
non mi stupì è proprio questo il fatto
che non mi stupisco più di niente
domani bedian cinefan
sono le pensiline ho capito che cucine
sardegna l'avevo capito prima ancora
della sicilia è tenero io creo chi li
ignori o un no kata di tensione
ricchini li voglio tutti
insomma niente gelato lune da bere passi
avanti cristo
[Musica]
non ho idea di cosa sia
io ho giocato al primo ma non mi ha
preso così tanto in realtà vabbè aspetta
pagati
[Applauso]
si aspetta è cosa mi sto facendo la mia
carriera era la bene giocherà e una è la
maionese
c'è una maionese veramente brutta a
vedersi
assurdo
stanno ancora motivo lo sa più cos'è
anni si occupa di ricerca contrario ma
se cerca per le peggiori e i miei quella
beh non che voi siete messi meglio in
realtà un po eccola è tornata madre
gelatina il rapporto perfetto speciali
capisco dove stia la ama niente giorno
[Musica]
quando tutta grinta una lezione di
processi da 36 giapponese unica
ma cos'è cosa sosta i concorsi cos'è un
caso è arrivato buio salvezza non avrò
mai abbastanza di bambini giapponesi che
urlano de agostini vi prego un'altra
volta
[Applauso]
che figata che comunque la d'agostini è
arrivata in giappone
[Musica]
se una persona stesse facendo una roba
del genere in mezzo della gente propria
mente arrivare nella polizia in tre
secondi però continuava a quello
sistemarsi stava immergendo questo
guarda c'è la maschera questi due non
sanno neanche cosa succede stavano
pescando vai via arrestate quest'uomo
[Musica]
talenti 2000 quali
vi prego date un contratto discografico
con guarda e credibile ci chiede di wall
street finalmente qualcosa da bere che
rimarcavano con giocate grazie e certo
ma con e amazon
buongiorno che dai costini no è una
tutina 28 mila yen
beh mi fa solo da matt e non te ne frega
una sega perché c'è il kf cieli etici
puglisi
[Musica]
questa è l'unica che ecco siamo arrivati
alla fine peccato che l'unica pubblicità
che ho capito è stata alla fine l'ultima
profili sia piaciuto ragazzi che saranno
pista giapponesi di oggi è sempre meglio
sempre ogni video e lo preferisco sempre
il popolo prima non vedo l'ora di vedere
il prossimo però che avevi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come sempre iscrivetevi al
canale sia stato mi piace se vi è
piaciuto
noi ci vediamo alla prossima puntata di
reaction la pubblicità giapponesi sul
mio canale e tanta altra roba molto
strana beh ragazzi
[Musica]